vamos a platicar un poquito más acerca
de coeficientes de requisitos de reserva
y luego si me da tiempo voy a hablar de
un concepto relacionado que a veces se
confunde con esto y que se llama
apalancamiento pero bueno comencemos con
requisitos de coeficiente de reserva
supongamos que en la jurisdicción en la
que vivimos o sea en el pueblo o aldea
ese requisito es de 10% esto qué quiere
decir eso quiere decir que por cada peso
que yo tenga en una cuenta de cheques
baja en una cuenta de cheques o que haya
emitido en notas bancarias entonces debo
tener al menos 10% de eso
pues en lo que sea que sea el recurso de
reserva en nuestro mundo hasta ahorita
ha sido oro en el mundo real ya no es
oro por ejemplo en eeuu todo está
respaldado en dólares suaviza nos
quedamos en oro después nos saldremos
del patrón oro y vamos a ver qué sucede
pero bueno vamos a hacer el ejemplo
desde cero una vez más para ver qué
tanto podemos aumentar la hoja de
balance y como este requisito hace que
no se haga demasiado grande entonces
tengo aquí el banco tengo mi edificio
que vale si empiezas de oro y luego lo
capitalice con otras 200 piezas de oro
200 piezas de oro este de aquí es el
edificio ya no lo dibujé y esto de la
derecha es mi capital es el capital con
el cual empecé y empecé con 300 piezas
de oro de capital capital sabes que
debería hacerlo con otro color porque
luego se confunde con el pasivo porque
ambos están del lado derecho lo voy a
poner así en rosa entonces esto de aquí
es el capital va ahora voy a empezar a
recibir algunos depósitos vamos a
suponer que son poquitos para que no se
haga muy grande la hoja entonces vamos a
suponer que recibo 100 piezas de oro en
depósitos
si empiezas
de depósitos ahora tengo un pasivo
correspondiente que son cuentas que voy
a hacer en morado con cuentas
voy a poner que son cuentas de cheques
va esto de aquí son cuentas de cheques
esto de aquí sería mi pasivo mi pregunta
es si hasta ahora tengo estos depósitos
o más bien si tengo este oro en reservas
que tanto puedo prestar o sea que tanto
puedo expandir mi hoja de balance pues
como el coeficiente debe ser 10%
entonces la razón que tiene que haber
entre mis reservas y el pasivo exigible
que que creé haciendo cuentas de
depósitos y así tiene que ser al menos
10 por ciento esto debería de decirnos
que el lado derecho la verdad no puede
crecer mucho vamos a meternos con las
cuentas entonces ahorita tenemos 100
brincos ahorita tenemos 100 piezas de
oro en pasivo exigible y ahorita no
vamos a hacer distinción entre depósitos
y notas bancarias porque desde el punto
de vista de la hoja de balance va a ser
lo mismo bueno por otro lado tengo 300
piezas de oro y eso está muy bien porque
tengo más en reservas que en pasivo y
bueno
esto fue porque yo capital hice desde el
inicio con oro mío ahora sí cuánto puedo
prestar pues saber este requisito dice
que únicamente puedo expandir el lado
derecho de la hoja de balance siempre y
cuando es el lado derecho
bueno el 10% de ese lado derecho siga
siendo menor que mi reserva es decir
esta cosa que estoy marcando en naranja
va ya con el problema como hacemos la
cuenta pues pensemos lo matemáticamente
10 por ciento tiene que ser igual a mis
reservas 300 piezas de oro que tengo en
reservas 100 de depósitos 200 que yo
metí como capital verdad eso de ahí era
mi oro dividido entre la cantidad total
de pasivo exigible le voy a poner
depósitos exigibles porque son depósitos
más notas bancarias pero estamos ahorita
haciendo lo más sencillo son depósitos
exigibles va
entonces hacemos un poquito de
matemáticas multiplicamos por los
depósitos tenemos 10 por ciento de los
depósitos tiene que ser igual a 300
piezas de oro dividimos entre punto 1
ambos lados entonces los depósitos
pueden ser hasta 3 mil hasta 3 mil
piezas de oro va entonces cuánto puedo
expandir mi hoja de balance pues puedo
seguir haciendo préstamos hasta que
tenga 3.000 piezas de oro en depósitos
exigibles entonces pues ya vamos a
empezar a prestar dinero entonces viene
alguien y me dice ay sabes que quiero
construir una fábrica que está así bien
padre iba a costar 900 piezas de oro yo
digo que ese sí claro se las prestó ahí
te van entonces lo voy a poner así no
está más no está tan alto como debería
no importa 1900 piezas de oro en
préstamo y pues no le doy oro verdad no
le doy piezas de oro reales sino que le
hago una cuenta de cheques entonces son
900 piezas de oro en una cuenta de
cheques con esto ya pueden escribir
cheques o pueden retirar del cajero le
pagan a los obreros lo que sea hacen su
proyecto va hasta ahorita cuánto va a
ver tenemos
cuando tenemos 900 100 ver aquí arriba
son 900 van mil entonces me queda 2000
para prestar supongamos que ahora llega
un segundo emprendedor y quiere hacer un
proyecto muy muy grande no sé digamos un
puente si un puente para la isla está
buena la idea luego va a cobrar peaje
suena muy bien le pregunto cuánto
necesita si dice en 2000 yo digo uf es
un montón pero vas te lo voy a prestar
hago un préstamo de dos mil y luego en
vez de darte oro y en vez de darle a oro
a esta persona voy a dar pues no sé le
voy a hacer una cuenta de cheques de dos
mil otra vez puede escribirse kees van
con este préstamo se me acabó porque
cuánto tengo en total tengo dos mil más
900 más 100 en depósitos exigibles que
son tres mil piezas de oro muy bien y
eso de ahí hasta ahorita es todo mi
pasivo verdad a lo mejor en otra
circunstancia hubiera pedido un préstamo
de otra forma pero ahorita no este es
todo mi pasivo entonces cuál es la razón
entre el total de mis reservas que son
estas 300 piezas de oro y el total de
mis pasivos exigibles que es tres mil
apuestas justas 300 entre 3.000 punto 1
10% como en la aldea hay un requisito de
coeficiente de reserva de 10% entonces
ya no puedo prestar nada más va ya
llegue al tope de lo permitido la
pregunta ahora es de qué sirve este
coeficiente de reserva pues la respuesta
corta es que me da liquidez qué quiere
decir esto pues básicamente es que si
las personas vienen a pedir oro entonces
yo pueda pagar una buena cantidad de ese
oro que piden entonces por ejemplo si
estas personas que conoces entre ellas
podrían pagarse con cuentas de cheques y
así pero si por alguna razón de estas
personas hay algunas que quieren que se
les devuelva su dinero en oro de lo que
se asegura el coeficiente es que yo
pueda dar ese oro bueno siempre y cuando
no llegue más del 10% de las personas va
entonces el coeficiente de reserva es
una cosa que garantiza que un banco
tenga liquidez que pueda pagarle a las
personas una cantidad esté razonable
cuando piden su dinero
una pregunta distinta es si soy solvente
solvente simplemente es que con tiempo
puedas pagar todo o sea que tus activos
le ganen a los pasivos vamos a ver si en
este ejemplo somos solventes en este
ejemplo mis activos son aversión
este 3000 más otras 300 creo que aquí
van si en verdad quieren 100 por el
edificio entonces mis activos son 3 mil
300 piezas de oro
también soy solvente porque siempre y
cuando mis activos que es todo el lado
izquierdo de la hoja de balance siempre
cuando mis activos regalen a mis pasivos
entonces soy solvente lo cual quiere
decir que bueno supongamos que a ver hay
temas supongamos que el mundo por alguna
razón la gente quiere oro viene y me
piden no sé 400 piezas de oro ahora en
ese momento no voy a poder pagarles no
voy a tener liquidez verdad no tengo
esos reservas para dárselo no se los
puedo dar inmediatamente entonces tengo
un problema de liquidez tal vez tenga
que tomar prestado oro pero voy a hacer
solvente suponiendo que estas dos estos
dos préstamos son buenos porque porque
si alguien me diera suficiente tiempo
estos préstamos me los pagarían o podría
venderle estos activos a alguien más y
obtener 900 piezas de oro y pues ya
podría pagar las piezas de oro que me
están pidiendo pero bueno sólo quería
mostrarte esta diferencia entre liquidez
y solvencia como se me está acabando
déjame platicarte y déjame platicarte
que voy a hacer en el siguiente vídeo te
voy a mostrar de qué se trata el
apalancamiento y el apalancamiento tiene
mucho más que ver con solvencia que con
liquidez para darte una probadita el
apalancamiento es que colchoncito tienes
para soportar pérdidas antes de que
caigas en insolvencia antes de que tus
pasivos le ganen a tus activos cuantas
pérdidas puedes soportar antes de
quebrar pero bueno nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo nada más hable de
reservas o sea en este no en el
siguiente en el siguiente si va
apalancamiento en fin nos vemos